speaking of bigotry against a group of
people is there any more
persecuted group in this country than
christian bakers
this poor guy you know jack phillips he
is the the guy who runs masterpiece cake
shop
we've had him on this show before years
ago jack phillips
he's a christian guy he's a baker and
political radicals keep targeting him
so for a while these these activists
trying to redefine marriage they go into
his bake shop they say we want you to
create a custom cake for our gay wedding
and jack phillips said well you know i
according to my religious lights the
phrase gay wedding
is isn't is nonsensical uh because
marriage involves the sexual difference
and moreover
my religion tells me i can't participate
in that
ceremony so sorry you can buy any of our
cakes
but i can't i can't contribute my art
toward
this the ceremony that i i view with
moral and program
so he gets sued goes all the way up to
the court he's been litigated all this
there are plenty of bakeries around jack
phillips there are plenty of other bake
shops that they could go to
that would participate in the ceremony
jack phillips doesn't want to but it's
not enough
it's not enough to say live and let live
okay i do what i want to do you do what
you want to do
that's just not how politics works and
the left understands this and the right
i think doesn't really understand this
doesn't understand this jack phillips
must be made to violate his moral
conscience
if this radical political regime is to
survive and flourish
jack phillips must be brought down he
must be made to obey
the politically correct dictates of the
day so now they're suing him again
some lawyer calls him up and says hey i
want you to bake a cake
that celebrates a gender transition
jack phillips says i can't do that i
think that's wrong
violates my conscience i also don't
think it's possible
so i'm not i can't do that you can buy
any of our cakes but i can't participate
and create a custom work for you
so he's getting sued again all in the
name of
of tolerance all in the name of
liberation the people who are doing this
who are persecuting jack phillips
for his religious views and not even
just his religious views before
defending the traditional american way
of life
for defending a view of sex and nature
and marriage
that has been held by everyone
everywhere at all times in history
except for like five minutes ago right
here in the west
the people doing that really think
they're the good guys
they really think that by ruining this
baker's
life they are the good guys
it's like that old sketch you know they
don't realize they're the baddies
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video